hello looks like we are live
uh
hello everyone sal here from khan
academy welcome to the daily homeroom
for those of y'all that this is the
first time that you're joining this is
really a way to connect and uh realize
that we're all part of a global
community here especially in this time
of school closures obviously khan
academy we're not for profit
mission-free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and well before this
crisis we're going through was happening
obviously our vision was how could we
support teachers how do we support
students how do we support parents so
that any child
and any teacher can support that child
to go through the core subjects from
pre-k elementary school middle school
high school in the core of college uh
across subjects and grades uh i will
remind folks that we are not for profit
and so we're able to do all of this with
philanthropic support from folks like
yourself and so we've always had those
resources but when we saw the school
closures happening we realized that it's
our duty as a not-for-profit in the
space that is free that it's accessible
to do whatever else we can to make sure
that you feel supported so above and
beyond the many subjects and grades that
we offer in math english language arts
science uh and the humanities on khan
academy we've been trying to do these
live streams which are just a way to
connect and make announcements and focus
on specific topics that are front of
mind for folks during the school
closures and also things like teacher
webinars parent webinars we've also been
experimenting even with
live classrooms at a very large scale
with students so that we can answer
their questions on topics like algebra i
do want to give a special thanks you
know khan academy was already running a
little bit of a deficit before all of
this hit
for us to be able to do our mission and
uh now that our server costs are going
up 2x maybe approaching 3x we need as
much support as possible i want to thank
folks like bank of america who's the
first to step up followed closely by 18t
google.org and novartis but we need more
help from corporations from everyone
whatever you can donate is great so i am
very excited today about today's topic
because
it's actually a topic that many of you
have been asking about it's a it's a
topic that i desperately want to learn
about as a father of a five-year-old who
in this time of social distancing is you
know not to pick on him uh maybe the
most disruptive member of our household
right now
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to bring on uh caroline who is actually
the founder of khan academy kids and
maybe a good place to start caroline is
actually how did this start what is khan
academy kids even before the school
closures happened and then we can talk a
little bit about what we're trying to do
together to support folks even more
sure so khan academy kids for those of
you who don't know is an educational
program
for kids ages two through seven and it
includes thousands of activities across
a variety of subjects
math reading language as well as social
emotional development and executive
function skills
so it's a comprehensive program for
early learning for preschool through
grade one
and it has a personalized learning path
where we adapt the lessons for each
child's skill level on specific topics
it also includes a library that has
hundreds of books
many of which are original books
around our characters and then we also
have some partnerships with national
geographic super simple and bell weather
to deliver some of the other books and
content
and as a reminder this is all free all
night commercial and i want to give
caroline and her husband michael credit
because they're the co-founders of what
became khan academy kids and i think
it's important for folks to realize that
you know similar to how khan academy
started as a not-for-profit is really a
family project uh a way for me to help
my cousin and word got around the free
tutoring was going on it started being
many everyone's cousins maybe you
started also as a family project you and
michael actually created some of the
very first apps uh back in 2008 2009
2010
on on devices that showed the world that
these could actually be things that
young children can interact with and
then you all essentially donated your
team donated your org to this mission so
i don't think i'm overstating it that
you know this isn't like some corporate
effort we're not trying to sell people
with you and michael it's a family
project you have other incredible team
members it's really an act of love that
you're trying to do that you started for
your family and then you're trying to do
for many others
that's right we've been working in early
childhood for
10 years on this and so um yep
and your background shows that you have
a much better background than i do and i
need to get some finger painting done
that might help yeah so let me
let let me let me start with a couple of
uh questions i think uh as i mentioned
um
the
the
early learning crowd is especially with
parents working from home preschools
have been closed kindergartens have been
closed uh
they're they're some of the most
difficult i think to you know say hey
why don't you just work on this for a
little bit what advice do you have for
parents generally speaking uh and uh
potentially leveraging khan academy kids
as well in the in this time of closures
yeah i mean i'd say as a parent myself
and sal as a parent of young children as
well
all i can say is you know give yourself
a break and be kind to yourself to start
with because all of us have been
unexpectedly thrown into this situation
um already as parents of young children
we were
very busy um being parents and juggling
a million other things and now we've
been catapulted into many other roles of
teacher carer magician
um among other things and um there's
just so much going on i'd say
be kind to yourself first and foremost
and also we're in this you know for the
long haul and so i think this is a new
normal that we're all adjusting to
we are working hard on
some things that we think might help but
i think the the biggest advice would be
to
think of this as a balance you're going
to be balancing
some learning time with your kids as
well as play time and academic time
and outside time
so it's really just about the balance
and um
it's not a sprint we're just going to
have to adjust to this new normal and so
a few things that we're
doing that we think may help in addition
to the core khan academy kids program is
just like sal is doing these daily home
rooms we're launching today
daily circle time which is like circle
time in preschools and kindergartens and
first grades where the teachers have a
chance to connect with the students so
sophie from my team and i will be
leading these circle times and they're a
time for
us to connect read books do learning
activities get the kids up to stretch
and do some imaginary play too we're
trying to keep some semblance of what's
abnormal during these changing times
and i think we're just really
acknowledging that
you know these are are
difficult difficult times for many
families and children so the children
may not know
the specifics of what covid19 is but
they are going through change maybe
their school is closed maybe their
parents are working at home or their
parents are just much busier and more
concerned about different things so
we're trying to address those head-on
and our first episode is a special
episode about how to talk to kids
um through these changing times and what
we're doing is instead of just
explaining the specifics of the virus
which may they might not you know it may
not be age-appropriate
um we are giving them three superpowers
that they already have that they can use
tools in times of change so things like
being thankful
belly breathing and being a helper
um so in addition to circle time
i think yeah for kids of all age as well
as parents and so i think you know as
parents watch with their kids
they can do it together you want to do
it together
i love them
already
i know yeah i have the belly so i might
as well use it to breathe
so let me ask there's a lot of great
questions that are already pouring in on
i want to get to as many of them but i'm
going to start with a selfish question
that i think is a lot of folks are
asking um
you know especially with younger ages
we're always sensitive to screen time
and by definition khan academy kind of
got me kids it's on the screen
but now we're in this new normal as you
mentioned where screens are in some ways
our only lifeline to the outside world
or socialization how are you thinking
about i know you all are consulting a
lot of experts child psychologists
researchers what are they telling you
what what do you know about uh
appropriate use of screen time generally
and screen time in the context of khan
academy kids
yeah i think as i was alluding to
earlier it's all about balance so
we definitely don't want the young kids
just on the screen so we need to balance
a few minutes in the morning up to 10 to
20 to 30 minutes um on something like
khan academy kids that's rich and
educational and enriching where the you
can see the kids um interacting with the
technology and singing and even getting
up sometimes to sing along and stomp
around um but we need to balance that
with outdoor time and
play time family time free time
as well as reading reading real books or
parents can also read books in our app
in the library and when they do it
together you know it's a very different
experience than
a child just looking at technology so
again just about balance
and just out of curiosity i mean we've
been seeing uh the traffic on our side
on kind of the core khan academy or
non-con academy kids up about two and a
half fold i i'm
we're using this as a meeting
what are you all seeing on downloads and
and what information over the last two
weeks
yeah well um overall since our launch in
2018 khan academy kids has been
downloaded over six million times um has
had great usage but this week is really
an anomaly we've seen our new users up
by over 10 times our normal rates
so wow you know very happy to be a
resource that parents and teachers and
and families can draw upon
great great so let me get to some of the
questions that i i'm seeing
so
uh there's there's one question my child
is on the autism spectrum do you have
any tips for using the khan kids app
with children with autism how can i make
sure it's engaging and motivating for
him
so we've heard from families with
children on the spectrum and it
children are all different and
i think our app is designed to be
engaging and easy to use for all
children so it's designed for
pre-readers and designed to be intuitive
for children to explore and
there's no
you know one way to use it and i think
with the core
characters that we have in our app they
tend to really can children connect with
these characters they all have different
personalities so different children can
latch onto different characters and then
we use a lot of music so as sal was
saying this is a homegrown effort
co-founder and husband plays the cello
in the app and we uh do a lot of the
music in our app ourselves and all of
the illustrations and
um character books are all done in-house
by our very talented animators and
illustrators so
um
yeah i think it is an app that you know
the pre-readers as well as children of
different abilities can um use in
different ways
i have to say caroline whenever i come
over to your house i have a little bit
of insecurity as a parent uh when i see
your family like let's bring out our
cellos and play together
there's something of a something of a of
a role model for me as a as me
personally my wife does a much better
job but i'm i i have aspirations um
let's see we have other questions
so this is
this is from youtube
cree henge
wants to know how would you use con for
khan academy kids if there isn't a
translation for their language yet and i
have some ideas there but i'm curious
what you think caroline
yeah well we've heard from families from
all over the world that they're using it
to learn english is one thing but again
as i was saying it was it's been
designed for pre-readers
so um
children can play with the interactive
activities do the counting and the
logic as well as you know listen to the
books that are read aloud in english
even if they don't know then i think
kids learn really quickly
so that's one way we've seen it being
used
yeah exactly because it's literally at a
level for when people are literally just
learning language and numbers and
motor skills and social emotional
learning that actually almost
a child anywhere can actually interact
with it and in many parts of the world
it's actually a really useful skill to
actually have some of that baseline
english proficiency but you know longer
term we might be able to think about
ways to
to localize
all right so other questions so see from
facebook andre felipe says i was
wondering if connecticut has a course on
how to teach online of course everything
is explained so well whether you're
being very generous andre and clearly
because of covet 19 i'm forced to teach
online so i think i can handle that
question um we don't have any courses on
that yet uh my advice to you and this
goes back to when i was tutoring for my
cousins and that was really a blessing
that i started with my cousins because
it it allows me not put too much
pressure on myself is just get started
uh there's many ways you can do it you
can use your cell phone you had a white
board you you can find some you know you
can go on online and buy a a a camera
a phone holder stand that you can point
downwards and you can do lectures on
paper
you obviously can also do what i do
which is a digital i use an art program
i use sketchbook and you can i do screen
capture using camtasia and i have a
decent microphone this is you know
something you can buy at your local
electronics store and you could do it
that way but that's a technical setup
and my advice on how to do it is just
you know be yourself uh don't sometimes
when people get recorded they can freeze
up a little bit or get a little stressed
out
be yourself laugh at yourself feel like
you're you know these are your students
you're talking to feel like you're
talking to them feel like you're talking
to your cousins and i think the more you
just get started get a lot of feedback
from them keep iterating on it i think
you're going to develop your own style
it'll be pretty cool
see other questions um
from facebook trixie hanson says can you
guys do a live tutoring on youtube
facebook for students if they need help
only using their khan academy work
and then
and then there's a second part why can't
my parents print a report card if all of
my progress and assignment scores online
so uh trixie we actually are exploring
some of those things uh like a youtube
we've actually been doing these webinars
we've been publicizing it on our on
social media and on the link on that uh
daily schedule that we put out which are
schedules for students of different age
groups including the khan academy kids
crowd to structure their days we've been
saying we've been running some
experiments and starting with algebra
where we've been working through algebra
worked examples but we're making them as
interactive as possible where students
can answer the questions you know answer
surveys we can see what they did and
then we can answer their questions so
expect to see some more of that we're
trying to as much as we can
and you know print a report card of
progress
in theory they can you know we haven't
built specific functions for i guess you
could say formal printable report cards
but the teachers and parent dashboards
have reports on uh if you if they are a
student's coach
what the student has been working on
what they've gotten mastery in what
assignments they've completed so in
theory that could be printed printed out
so
from youtube anusha amith asks can you
use khan academy kids on a computer
caroline
unfortunately not yet uh
it's more for mobile devices on ios and
android as well as chromebooks
but wait with the circle time you'll be
able to see that on on youtube we also
are coming out with daily often
activities where children can do math
and reading offline in printable or
using things around their house so
things like mondays writing workshop
wednesdays and thoughtful thursdays
and just to add to what caroline says
you know the
this is all free not for profit so
whether you're on android or ios you can
download this app there's no shady
upselling this is literally free
philanthropically supported so we need
your help to uh to keep khan academy
kids going especially with the load
we're seeing 10x of of normal load we
already had six million downloads before
this and now we're 10x of normal load so
we need your help but this is all free
this is all non-commercial so hopefully
it's accessible to you and your children
anusha
so
from youtube we have astrojayden says
hey sal this is jaden i'm wondering if i
can change up my schedule to fit my day
i'm in sixth grade and there's no
telling how each day will go
and my answer to you
or or response astro is absolutely the
whole goal of those schedules are to be
a starting point allow people to realize
okay i got this this is a reasonable way
to handle it but feel free to copy it
paste it modify it so it meets your
needs so that it can meet your day and i
think it sounds like you do want to have
some type of a schedule which does help
structure your days especially in you
know when we're when we're all spending
a lot of time at home which i think is a
really great thing i think that's
actually a great skill as a sixth grader
that you're developing is just like that
meta skill of okay how should i
structure my day how should i plan how
should i make sure i get everything done
that i want to so
good job astro
okay
another question and this is from
youtube littlegummy34
hi sal why are missions going down on
khan academy all right that's a that's a
very good question that i'm sure many
people are asking
uh missions is actually uh so for those
of you who don't know historically over
the last 10 years there's really been
two ways to experience kind of really
three ways
one is you do a web search on a concept
factoring quadratics and then you get go
to the right part of khan academy and
you could do it that way we've
historically called that the library
view and then there's this thing called
missions where if you find the missions
on say algebra or other subjects
it will be kind of a guided practice and
there's game mechanics and all these
notions of mastery and what we realized
about four or five years ago is missions
actually has a lot of efficacy research
behind it but we realized it was kind of
unfortunate that there were these two
worlds our ideal world is to do what a
good tutor would do is that you come to
us for help through a web search and
then we help you for your immediate
needs and maybe you're you're trying to
learn something for a test tomorrow or
do your homework but then the game
mechanics of things like missions kind
of suck you in in a good way and so what
we started building about two years ago
is what we call course mastery so now
when you do a search and you fall into
khan academy you can get your immediate
help get some practice and feedback but
there's already mastery mechanics around
it and so what we the reason why we're
going to you know the fancy word is
deprecate missions which means over the
next year or so we're going to be taking
it down is because the course mastery is
being able to pick up the slack of what
missions was doing before and so that's
my simple answer and then we are
committed to continually improving that
course mastery so not only does it do
everything that missions did we just
launched things like mastery challenges
on our course mastery but we hope it
goes there and beyond and has all of the
benefits of our library view but that's
an excellent question
all right so
from youtube daniel marazida asks what
is the difference between a mastery
challenge and assignments our
assignments just a focus mastery
challenge is a mission master shows okay
so we're going deep into the experience
but these are good questions because i
know there are a lot of folks especially
with the school closure spending more
time at khan academy you're using it as
the resource that you're really leaning
on
so a mastery so there's when you do
skills and i'll just say math but we
have mastery in other subjects as well
you can focus on that skill and it might
ask you to do five questions and if you
get four right it'll say you're familiar
if you get five out of five it's a it'll
say you're fluent and then there's
another level called mastery and the
only way that you get mastery is if
you're already fluent and you get that
question right in either
a
a
unit test which is sampling all of the
skills of the unit a mastery challenge
or a course challenge and the reason why
we do that is we feel that you only are
truly mastering it when you know when to
recognize to do that problem and you're
seeing it with other problems and you
have to kind of remember
my maybe how to apply some of those
concepts or skills mastery challenges
are things we just launched and they're
they always exist in missions where not
only do they allow you to up level these
things that you are already
proficient in
but they also are doing what's called
space repetition so we know that you can
learn something we've all experienced it
but a month later two months later you
might have forgotten it
and especially with a lot of these
skills it's really important to retain
it over time and so there's a lot of
learning science behind it but mastery
challenges beyond being just an
opportunity to up level the skills that
you're already proficient in it's also a
chance to make sure that you still have
mastered things from before so mastery
challenges tend to be a little bit
shorter take a little less time they're
good ways to level up and they're good
ways to review unit tests are great ways
if you're just trying to get mastery in
that unit you're trying to understand
what your gaps are in that unit
and you're trying to level up and course
challenges are great if you want to
understand your understanding of the
whole course maybe figure out where your
gaps are
and then zero in on those units that you
might be having difficulty with but this
is all great feedback for us to just
make all of this
that much that much clearer
um let's see other questions we have we
have a little bit more time i'm seeing
if they're
if they're let me ask another um
khan academy kids question for caroline
from uh youtube i'll go marble racer
says when was the app created i'm
assuming they're talking about the we
have two apps we have the khan academy
app and the khan academy kids app i'd
love to you know when was the khan
academy kids app created and kind of how
do you see it evolving
yeah so we uh launched khan academy kids
in 2018 so it's been out for a little
over a year and it is
rapidly evolving we are working on more
tools to help in this environment of
remote learning and so stay tuned in the
next few weeks we'll have some
announcements about new things that we
can use for remote learning um currently
it goes from preschool through grade one
will be aging up to grade two as well
over time
and you know i can't um i can't
overstate how powerful what uh what
caroline michael and their team have
created you know you saw you saw some
videos of it but it's somewhat magical
because the videos kind of pause and
then the kids are asked to manipulate
what was actually in the video as you
know so it's and i i have as i mentioned
a five-year-old and and he loves it and
there's also plenty of books in there
things that you can read alongside of
your children uh you know i think it's
you seeing in some of these videos this
is kind of the best use case the family
gets together does it together it's a
time to connect and we also know there
are times in this you know where you're
trying to get some work and you want to
say what is the nutritious screen time
for your child where you can feel
confident they're learning and
caroline's been doing some incredible
work with researchers from places like
stanford to measure the efficacy to
constantly iterate on it so this isn't
just pure edutainment where it's like
entertainment that kind of looks kind of
educational this is real education that
happens to be engaging and really
entertaining and i think they've done a
a really incredible job at that so let's
see other questions maybe time for
time for
uh one question this is so from youtube
roshan
rangdal asks my sister's week in basic
math how do i help her
so depending on her age one suggestion
if she's you know mid elementary or a
little older late elementary element or
middle school ace or even high school i
actually recommend going on khan academy
and starting at the beginning starting
on early learning which i think she'll
be able to go through quite quickly
especially if she uses things like
course challenges and then go to
uh things try to finish the arithmetic
on khan academy and then she could
probably engage on her grade level
depending what it is but you know with
school closures the silver lining is
there might be a little bit more time to
really go all the way back and build
those foundations i'm confident if your
sister is listening uh tell her that
it's not that she's bad at math or or
not capable or that math is hard it's
just that she probably got some gaps in
her background and then now things are
making a little less sense but if she
goes back fills in those gaps not only
will she find that math is fun and
interesting but she can be quite good at
it
so i think that's all of our time today
and time really does go by fast when
you're having fun i wanted to thank
caroline we're going to post information
about all of the amazing things that
caroline and her team are doing already
and uh the live events they're going to
be holding over uh the weeks and maybe
months to come depending on how long uh
this closure situation lasts uh and i
just want to remind everyone we are not
for profit everything we're doing is
free it's not commercial it's made
possible uh through donations from folks
like yourself and we do genuinely need
that help to stay afloat i always tell
people our budget is about the budget of
a large high school but we are trying to
serve a decent chunk of humanity right
now
especially through this school closure
period and khan academy is much more
than just me and caroline it's over 200
folks we have thousands of volunteers we
have to spend millions of dollars just
on server hosting you can imagine
there's a tens of millions of people who
are depending on this every month right
now so with that uh everyone you know
stay safe stay socially distanced just
remember we're all in this together and
uh there's you know it's a hard time but
there's something beautiful about this
shared experience as well and and i
really love being connected uh to all of
y'all in this way now i i and our team
will we'll see you tomorrow
you